[موسيقى]
فتحت الستاره التانيه على الشهيد الثاني
واول ما فتحت ستاره شفت جانب وجهه ومسكت
وجهه بايدي ولفيته علي
وهون تاكدت انه ابوي
[موسيقى]
انا الياس عبد العزيز محمد اشقر عمري 25
سنه
بعمل ممرض في مستشفى النجاح الجامعي احنا
العاملين في القطاع الصحي عرفنا باجتياح
نابلس من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بحدود
الساعه تمانيه تقريبا عرفنا انه الجيش
الاحتلال دخل
لنابلس ضرب جرس الانذار في قسم الطوارئ
ونزلنا انا واصدقائي من العنايات المكثفه
بحكم انه احنا الطاقم المتخصص للتعامل مع
حالات توقف القلب انزلنا بشكل سريع على
الطوارئ من اول ما دخلنا كان الوضع
كارثي صراحه
كانت الفوضى بكل مكان كل اشي بتحرك بركض
وناس بتصرخ الارض كلياتها دم وقطع ملابس
من
الجرحى والمصابين
والدي اسمه عبد العزيز محمد عبد العزيز
اشقر عمره 65 سنه متقاعد من وكاله الغوث
الدوليه بيعمل حاليا مدرب للسياقه ابوي
كان متواجد بمنطقه نوعا ما بعيدا عن منطقه
الاحداث هي منطقه في نابلس المدرسه اللي
بيشتغل فيها ابوي قريبه من هذا المستوصف
اللي يصادف كمان جنبهم وجود مسجد بعد صلاه
الظهر يعني بحدود الساعه 12:30 تقريبا
تتلقى الاصابه بكل صدر كان مليان شظايا
كان القلب مصاب اصابه مباشره والرئتين
كمان مصابات اصابه مباشره كان في تهتك عام
في جميع الاعضاء الداخليه
كان في بدايه الطوارئ سريرين المتقابلين
كان عليهم
الشهيدين
منهم والدي
كان فرق الانعاش حوالين كل المصاب بنهم
وكانوا يحاولوا يعملوا بعمليات الانعاش
كانوا يحاولوا يرجعوا لهم نبض القلب
وعلاماتهم الحيويه
لكن لحد اللحظه هاي ما كنتش اعرف انا انه
والدي واحد من مصابين
فدخلت اساعد كل الموجودين في قسم الطوارئ
بغض النظر عن اي جريح منهم كان في زميلنا
الدكتور جراح دكتور عيسى كان بيحاول يفتح
بصدر والدي وكنت انا اناوله الاشياء اللي
كان يطلبها الادوات اللي كان يطلبها
باللحظه هاي ما كنتش اعرف انه فاتح صدر
والدي اخر مريض وديته على قسم الاشعه
ورجعت اسال الطبيب انه ايش صار في
الحالتين اللي احنا بنحاول نعيش فيهم وقال
لي انه الحالتين توفوا
[موسيقى]
يعني واقع كلمه توفل لاول مره كنت احسه
غريب بالعاده احنا بالمستشفيات نتعامل
كثير مع حالات الوفيات لكن لاول مره كنت
احس انه موقعها غريب كانه في اشي بين
الاسرى بدور عليه في اشي لازم الاقيه بين
الاسره فتحت الستاره الاولى على الشهيد
الطفل محمد شعبان الله يرحمه
وبعديها رحت فتحت الستاره الثانيه على
الشهيد الثاني
واول ما فتحت ستاره شفت جانب وجهه عرفت
انه ابوي لكن
كذبت حالي وكذبت علي وكذبت اللي شفته
بهارات كواي مره واحده وبس حبيت اكمل لجنب
السرير لحتى اتاكد اكثر
وصلت لجنب السرير ومسكت وجهه بايدي ولفيته
علي
وهون تاكدت انه ابوي كل يعني من واهل
الصدمه انه انا كل الموجودين تحت بعرفهم
وزملائي لكن انا التفتت للشخص الوحيد اللي
هو رئيس قسمي الاستاذ احمد الاسود فالتفت
عليه قلت له احمد هذا ابوي كل الطوارئ سكت
كل شيء كان يتحرك وقف كل شيء كان يتكلم
صمد
[موسيقى]